what is up everybody it's anna mack
here for anime uproar and today i will
be discussing the latest events
in the attack on titan story
and this was just insane we got twist
after twist after twist a flying
titan shifter was just foreshadowed in a
very interesting way
and the final epic battle is about to
take place
very soon there is a lot to go over
and break down so let's get into it
if you enjoy the attack on titan content
right here on the channel and you want
us to keep it going please leave a like
to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
the channel or you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications this is the first
attack on titan video that i'm making
after this channel reached over 1
million subscribers
thank you guys so much for that it is an
incredible accomplishment but it is an
accomplishment that depends entirely
on each and every one of you thank you
finally this video will contain attack
on titan manga spoilers
we are dealing with the very latest
events in the story so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned the latest
installment of the story starts off with
the allies
sitting inside the airplane after they
barely escaped the rumbling
back in the previous chapter and of
course the only reason why the allies
got as far as they did was because
hanji sacrificed her life in order to
buy them time
not to mention the many other sacrifices
made along the way by people like mcgath
and shadis
and so on as a result of all this
tragedy and all these sacrifices
the mood on the airplane is somber to
say the least
while onyankunpon pilots the plane
reiner peak levi
connie jean and mikasa are all just kind
of there
their heads bowed in silence no doubt
they are all contemplating the terrible
things that they had to go through
all the way up to this point and the yet
more terrible things that surely await
them once they finally catch up to aaron
inside the cockpit on component tells
armin that they were only able to fuel
the plane
halfway they had to take off before the
tank was full
in order to escape the rumbling as a
result armin is understandably worried
that the plane won't have enough fuel to
actually reach salta the airship base
that aaron is believed to be heading
towards next but on yankon
vows that he will make it all the way to
aaron no matter what it takes
and in return he begs armin to stop the
rumbling
and save the world by any means
necessary
as armin leaves the cockpit and joins
the others in the back of the plane
he begins discussing the plan to stop
aaron and the rumbling armin draws a
crude sketch of aaron's massive
spider-esque titan
and armin compares it to an insect with
a lot of bones
as a result of its incredible size and
strain shape
there is almost no way to tell where
aaron's real body
is actually located because of this
trying to find aaron and cut him out of
the titan
seems virtually impossible the only
feasible option
seems to be using the massive explosion
ability of armin's colossal titan to
take out aaron's entire titan
or at least as much of it as possible
armin agrees that this is the best
option from a strategic perspective
but that would almost certainly kill
aaron since
armin and mikasa both want to avoid
killing aaron
armin wants to use the colossal titan
nuke as a weapon of last resort
before they commit to such drastic
measures armin wants to try to talk
to aaron and bring him back to his
senses pique and the others seem pretty
skeptical about this belief that aaron
can just be talked out of the rumbling
but then levi brings up another
potential strategy
since aaron was able to activate the
rumbling through zeke aaron doesn't have
royal blood so zeke's royal blood was
required for the founding titan power to
activate
then maybe if the allies can find and
kill zeke
the connection between aaron and the
founding titan will be severed
and the rumbling will stop that way only
zeke needs to die
but aaron doesn't levi and the others
don't know where zeke
is but levi swears that he will find
zeke and he will
kill him the assumption here is that
zeke's human body must
also be somewhere within or on top of
aaron's titan so if they can find and
kill zeke
maybe that will do the trick however i'm
not sure that finding zeke's body will
be any easier than finding aaron's body
but we'll have to wait and see
i guess maybe zeke's body is more
exposed than aaron's and maybe it will
somehow be visible from the air
but that's all speculation at this point
nonetheless
levi and zeke have quite a history at
this point
and for levi this is personal levi
wouldn't hesitate to kill aaron nearly
as much as mikasa and armin would
but if they can stop the rumbling by
killing zeke instead
so much the better for levi since he is
determined to get his revenge
after everything that zeke has put him
through as all of these conversations
are happening within the airplane
connie and jon have an interesting
moment with reiner now that coney and
jon had to kill their own former
comrades in order to carry out their
plan to stop
aaron they now kind of understand how
reiner and bertolt must have felt
after they infiltrated parodies reiner
tells them that the sins that they
committed can never be atoned for
but the very least they can do is try
their best to save the rest of humanity
reiner mentions that aaron had said
something similar to him back on the
night of the attack on liberio
aaron said that he can't condemn reiner
because he now understands what he had
to do
and how he must have felt while doing it
and after that
reiner says that maybe aaron actually
wants them to stop him
now that he has unlocked the power of
the founding titan
aaron has the ability to control all
ldns and all titans
and yet aaron has not taken away the
ability of the allies to use their titan
shifter powers
so far they've all been able to use
their titan powers freely
so maybe aaron chose not to interfere
with their powers
or their plans because he actually wants
to be stopped
he wants his former friends and comrades
to find
a better way after all as hard as aaron
might try
justifying it to himself wiping out
millions of people
all over the world is not something that
anyone would take lightly
maybe that burden is just too much for
him so he created a way out
for himself if the allies can reach him
and use their titan powers
maybe they can stop him and then aaron
won't have to go through
with the rumbling however in the very
next moment
everyone on board the plane except of
course for oyan konpon
is summoned by aaron into the world of
the paths
once again the two ackermans levi and
mikasa are also able to enter the paths
just like the ordinary aldians are levi
concludes that aaron must have been
listening in
on their conversation and honestly
judging by that very specific
timing i have to agree armin wants to
convince aaron that he doesn't need to
continue the rumbling because what he
has done so far has already ensured the
safety of parodies for centuries to come
no one else needs to die now because
after seeing what aaron is capable of
the rest of the world will have to agree
to sign a peace agreement
on aaron's terms in other words aaron
has made his point
loud and clear he doesn't have to go any
further
mikasa also calls out to aaron and asks
him to let her
share his burden finally even levi
speaks up
he tells aaron that he will kick his ass
only if he doesn't stop now
implying that aaron still has a way out
levi demands an answer from aaron
and then finally the allies hear
aaron's voice aaron says that he cannot
stop the rumbling because that would
mean
gambling with the future of parodies
armin and the others might be hoping
that what aaron has done so far will be
enough to maintain peace on parodies
but there is no guarantee that this
would be the case
and aaron has a point now that the walls
have been torn down
the other nations may be even more
likely to attack parodies
once they can regroup the walls were a
major deterrent for any ground force
trying to invade the island but those
walls are now
gone and of course we know that airship
and airplane technology is improving
rapidly
and this could prove to be devastating
for parodies if a new war breaks out
with that in mind there is just no way
that aaron can stop
now at least not before destroying forts
alta
suddenly the allies inside the paths see
that great pillar of light and as they
run towards it
they see aaron standing there but this
is not the adult
aaron from the present this is aaron as
a child
aaron at around the same age that he was
when the story first got
going as the allies shout all sorts of
questions at aaron
including the question of why he
continues to allow them to use their
titan shifter powers
aaron explains that he took the world's
freedom in order to achieve his own
but he will not steal the freedom of his
comrades
they are free free to save the world
from him
if they so choose just as he is free to
keep moving forward
unless they stop him we then see mere
fritz appear
right next to aaron and both emir and
aaron have those
creepy blacked out eyes it's almost as
if both emir
and aaron are now slaves for millennia
emir has been a slave to the royal
bloodline and the founding titan
and aaron now appears to be a slave to
his
own master plan as he himself said
he cannot turn back he cannot reconsider
he cannot negotiate he believes that he
has no
other choice if aaron and the people in
parodies are ever going to be free
truly free aaron must destroy the rest
of the world
so ironically aaron may have just become
a slave
to his own ideal of freedom he wants to
achieve his ideal of freedom so badly
and he believes that he can only achieve
it through his current plan
and so because of this in many ways
aaron is not free
he is not free to change his mind he is
not free to go back to the innocence of
his childhood
he is not free to reconcile with his
friends in some ways he has been
enslaved by his own
plan and his own convictions this is a
fascinating development when you think
about it
and i could spend literally hours
talking about aaron and freedom and the
different
often competing definitions of what
freedom is but
that might be a topic for another video
so for now let's move on when armin asks
aaron why he brought them here in the
first place
aaron explains that he wanted to tell
them that they cannot
change his mind or talk him out of the
rumbling the only way to stop aaron is
to end his life
and his comrades are free to do this if
that is their decision
and aaron wants them to know it now in
that moment
the allies find themselves back inside
the airplane
and they now know that bargaining with
aaron will not work
there will be no negotiating there will
be no debating there will be no trying
to talk him back to his senses
the rumbling will go all the way unless
they kill
aaron the chapter then switches focus to
the steamship where annie kiyomi gabby
and falco currently are
and it is on that ship that we arrive at
a massive
game-changing titan twist but we'll talk
about that in a little bit
annie thinks back to all the important
people in her life this includes her
father
her fellow warriors and of course her
comrades from the 104th training corps
finally she thinks of armin and all of
it breaks her heart
because it's too late it's too late for
liberio
it's too late for the survey core and
it's too late for her father
but in that moment of heartbreak and
desperation for annie
falco says something that seems kind of
random he says that he had
a dream however things change and
escalate really quickly
as we realize what kind of dream it was
and what it really means
falco says that this dream was not his
own
it was a dream or memory from zeke the
beast
titan since falco was turned into a
titan through
zeke's spinal fluid he seems to have
inherited some of the beast titan's
traits
along with some of zeke's memories
furthermore
according to gabby the female titan
seems to have a special ability that we
didn't really know
that much about and that ability is to
mimic
the power of another titan if she can
eat
a part of that titan first of all this
is crazy
and i will talk about it more later and
second of all
falco believes that if the female titan
has this ability
then perhaps his jaw titan can inherit
the abilities of the beast titan due to
his connection
to zeke's spinal fluid falco explains
that in this memory or dream that he has
been having
he can see himself flying above the
clouds
and falco feels deep within himself that
he can really do this
he can fly through the air with
his titan falco is convinced that
sometime in the past there had been a
winged
beast titan since falco's jaw titan has
clear bird-like features as i mentioned
in my previous videos
it is possible that falco's jaw titan
has inherited some of the traits
of this previous flying beast titan
this means that falco's jaw titan could
theoretically become
the first flying titan shifter that
we've ever
seen and if this is true it is not only
a massive twist
i mean fan speculations about a flying
titan have been rampant
ever since we first learned about the
titan shifters but this could also be a
major
game changer in my video on the previous
attack on titan chapter
i mentioned that i was surprised to see
annie taking herself
out of the final battle and effectively
benching herself
and the female titan after being stuck
in the crystal for so many years
it all seemed very anti-climactic from a
narrative perspective
why have annie break out of the crystal
after so many years
if she is just going to sit out the
final battle and bench
the female titan shifter if falco can
figure out how to make his titan fly
he can just take annie on his back and
fly her right
into the final battle if annie does
change her mind after all
and if falco's titan can fly then they
can both join the final battle later on
even though they didn't board that
airplane and this means that the final
battle will include
all nine titan shifters after all and i
mean this would only make sense from a
writing perspective
the final showdown in the final series
should include all the titan shifters
after this crazy revelation about
falco's titan
i am now convinced that falco and annie
will fly up to aaron
and join the final battle at some point
in the future
and that final battle will be absolutely
legendary the chapter then switches
focus yet again
this time to fort salta and the
surrounding area
we see a train heading towards the fort
and then we get
yet another big twist annie's dad
reiner's mom peaks dad and the families
of gabby and falco
are still alive in fact they seem to
have hijacked a train
and annie's dad is holding the train
conductor hostage at gunpoint
if you think back to chapter 125 we saw
annie's dad and the other aldians in
liberio
trying to explain to the marlene
soldiers that the rumbling
is coming the aldians had all received
aaron's message
through the paths but the merlions had
not and the soldiers refused to believe
what the aldians were saying in fact the
soldiers started beating the aldians
and it looked like there might be some
sort of alden rebellion happening within
liberia
but we never got to see what happened
with that potential rebellion
because the focus of the story shifted
to other things
it now seems that the rebellion did in
fact occur
and at least some of the ldns were able
to get out of the barrio using this
hijacked
train when we heard that all of the
barrier was already destroyed i kind of
assumed that all of these guys were in
fact dead
but this twist makes me think that
isayama might plan to have some sort of
happy
ish ending after all i mean if he just
wanted to kill off everyone he wouldn't
have gone through the trouble of having
all of these family members of the
warriors survive
so who knows maybe isama will show some
level of mercy to the remaining
characters
in the end the aldians on the train are
hoping to escape the rumbling by taking
control
of one of fort zalta's airships but as
the train approaches salta
an entire fleet of airships takes off
from the fort
in that moment the trained passengers
realized that the rumbling has
already caught up to them and all of
these airships are taking off
in a desperate attempt to fight back
against the rumbling
not only are the wall titans here but
aaron's gigantic titan
is here as well it looks like the fleet
of airships is about to bomb the wall
titans in an attempt to slow down the
rumbling
but even though i'm sure that the
airships possess some powerful
explosives i don't think anything short
of nukes will be able to stop the
rumbling
at this point however the fleet of
airships may slow down the rumbling long
enough for the passengers of the train
to get away so we'll have to wait and
see and that is how this
roller coaster of a chapter ends even
though we didn't get to see any crazy
titan fight
in this chapter we got so many twists
and turns
aaron summoning the allies through the
paths and explaining why they still have
their titan powers while at the same
time refusing to negotiate or
back down the reveal that the female
titan has the ability to mimic the power
of other shifters
if she consumes a portion of their
bodies then we got the huge twist that
falco's jaw titan may be capable of
flying
finally we learned that the families of
the warriors are actually alive
even though everyone had assumed that
they were dead wow
so much has happened in just a single
chapter of attack on titan i cover
multiple manga series on this channel as
you guys know
an attack on titan chapters rarely fail
to amaze me
this reveal about the female titan
changes everything that we thought we
knew about her
is her ability to harden parts of her
body a result of her consuming a part of
the
armored titan is her ability to call the
mindless titans to her
the result of consuming a part of the
beast titan
and are there other insane abilities
that she can yet
attain for example what happens if she
somehow consumes a portion of aaron's
gigantic titan there are so many
possibilities and this final showdown is
shaping up to be an absolute
scorcher and yes i am now convinced that
both annie and falco
will join the final fight and speaking
of falco
do you think that his titan really will
unlock the ability to fly
that is now the only way for all of the
titan shifters to participate in the
final battle
falco will have to fly himself and annie
right up to aaron
and i do believe that the story is
heading in that direction
do you guys agree and if you do what
will falco's flying titan's final form
look like
and what abilities will it have let me
know down below
finally does the survival of the
warriors families mean that isama might
choose a not so tragic ending after all
i mean there is already plenty of
tragedy to go around but does this twist
mean that isama is going to show mercy
to the characters who have survived
up to this point man i can't wait to see
what happens next
and as much as i don't want this series
to end i also can't wait to see
how it ends if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more attack on titan
content on the channel
please slap a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed make this the
video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications
once again thank you for over 1 million
subscribers
that is insane and you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar i want to give a big
thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma
and liam thompson disciples of lord
twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the
one-tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
jonathan king
rathuindeora emperor otaku thomas jones
kin mono
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
king zeldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octor hinokamian water
bonnie parks jason wilson florian
and garcia steelers mcshamus jessica
kayla fond
deadly saint stern hawkins and
highschool dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you